so 2014 was a big year for me do you
ever have that just like a big year like
a banner year for me it went like this
October 3rd I lost my second pregnancy
and then October 8th my dad died of
cancer and then on November 25th my
husband Aaron died after three years
with Stage four glioblastoma which is
just a fancy word for brain cancer
so I'm fun people love to invite me out
all the time
packed social life usually when I talk
about this period in my life the
reaction I get is essentially I can't I
can't imagine but I do think you can I
think you can and I think that you
should because someday it's gonna happen
to you
maybe not these specific losses in this
specific order or at this speed but like
I said I'm very fun and the research
that I have seen will stun you everyone
you love has a 100 percent chance of
dying and that's why you came to Ted
so since all of this last happened I've
made it a career to talk about death and
loss not just my own because it's pretty
easy to recap but the losses and
tragedies that other people have
experienced it's Anish I have to say
it's a small niche I wish I made more
money but I've written some very
uplifting books host a very uplifting
podcast I started a little nonprofit I'm
just trying to do what I can to make
more people comfortable with the
uncomfortable and grief is so
uncomfortable it's so uncomfortable
especially if it's someone else's grief
so a part of that work is this group
that I started with my friend mo who is
also a widow we call it the hot young
widows club and it's real we have
membership cards and t-shirts and when
your person dies your husband wife
girlfriend boyfriend literally don't
care if you were married your friends
and your family are just gonna sort of
look around through friends of friends
of friends of friends until they find
someone who's gone through something
similar and then they'll push you
towards each other so you can talk
amongst yourselves and not get your sad
on other people so that's what we do
it's just a series of small groups where
men women gay straight married partnered
can talk about their dead person and say
the things that the other people in
their lives aren't ready or willing to
hear yet huge range of conversations
like my husband died two weeks ago I
can't stop thinking about sex is that
normal yeah what if it's one of the
property brothers less normal but I'll
accept it
things like look when I'm out in public
and I see old people holding hands like
couples who have clearly been together
for decades and then I look at them and
I imagine like all of the things they've
been through together the good things
the bad things the arguments they've had
over who should take out the trash
I just find my heart filled with rage
and that example is personal to me most
of the conversations that we have in the
group can and will just stay amongst
ourselves but there are things that we
talk about that the rest of the world
the world that is grief adjacent but not
yet grief-stricken could really benefit
from hearing and if you can't tell I'm
only interested in slash capable of
unscientific studies so what I did was
go to the hot young widows Club and say
hello friends remember in your person
died they did do you remember all the
things people said to you
oh yeah um which ones did you hate the
most I got there were a lot of comments
a lot of answers people say a lot of
things but to rose to the top pretty
quickly moving on now since 2014 I will
tell you I have remarried
a very handsome man named Matthew we
have four children in our blended family
we live in the suburbs of Minneapolis
Minnesota USA we have a rescue dog I
Drive a minivan like the kind where
doors open I don't even touch um like
like by any measure
life is good I've also never said
measure I've never once said it that way
I don't know where that came from
I've never heard anyone else say it that
way but it looks like it should be said
that way and that's why the English
language is trash so impressed with
anyone who like speaks it in addition to
a language that makes sense so good job
but by any measure by any measure life
is really really good but I haven't
moved on I haven't moved on and I hate
that phrase so much and I understand why
other people do because what it says is
that Aaron's life and death and love are
just moments that I can leave behind me
and then I probably should and when I
talk about Aaron I slip so easily into
the present tense and I've always
thought that made me weird and then I
noticed that everybody does it and it's
not because we are in denial or because
we're forgetful it's because the people
we love who we've lost are still so
present for us so when I say oh Aaron is
it's because Aaron still is and it's not
in the way that he was before which was
much better and it's not in the way that
churchy people tried to tell me that he
would be it's just that he's indelible
and so he's present for me here he is
present for me in the work that I do and
the child that we had together in these
three other children I'm raising who
never met him who shared none of his DNA
but who are only in my life because I
had Aaron and because I lost Aaron he's
present in my marriage to Matthew
because Aaron's life and love and death
made me the person that Matthew wanted
to marry so I've not moved on from Aaron
I've moved forward with him
we spread Erin's ashes in his favorite
river in Minnesota and when the bag was
empty because when you're cremated you
fit into a plastic bag there were still
ashes stuck to my fingers and they could
have just put my hands in the water and
rinsed them but instead I licked my
hands clean because I was so afraid of
losing more than I had already lost and
I was so desperate to make sure that he
would always be a part of me but of
course he would be because when you
watch your person Phil himself with
poison for three years just so he can
stay alive a little bit longer with you
that stays with you when you watch him
fade from the healthy person he was the
night you met to nothing that stays with
you when you watch your son who isn't
even two years old yet walk up to his
father's bed on the last day of his life
like he knows what's coming in a few
hours and say I love you all done
bye-bye that stays with you just like
when you fall in love finally like
really fall in love with someone who
gets you and sees you and you even see
oh my god I've been wrong this entire
time love is not a contest or a reality
show it's so quiet it's this invisible
thread of calm that connects the two of
us even when everything is chaos and
things are falling apart even when he's
gone that stays with you we used to do
this thing because my hands are always
freezing and he's so warm where I would
take my ice cold hands and shove them up
his shirt press him against his hot bod
and he hated it so much but he loved me
and after he died I laid in bed with
Aaron and I put my hands underneath him
and I felt his warmth and I can't even
tell you if my hands were cold that I
can tell you that I knew it was the last
time I would ever do that
and then that memory is always going to
be sad that memory will always hurt
you've won in 600 years old and I'm just
a hologram just like the memory of
meeting him is always going to make me
laugh Greece doesn't happen in this
vacuum it happens alongside of and mixed
in with all of these other emotions so I
met Matthew my current husband doesn't
love that title
but it's so accurate I met Matthew and
there's this audible sigh of relief
among the people who love me like it's
over she did it she got a happy ending
we can all go home and we did good and
that narrative is so appealing even to
me and I thought maybe I've gotten that
too but I didn't I got another chapter
and it's such a good chapter I love you
honey it's such a good chapter but
especially at the beginning it was like
an alternate universe or one of those
old choose your own adventure books from
the 80s where there are two parallel
plot lines so I opened my heart to
Matthew and my brain was like would you
like to think about Aaron like the past
the present future like just get in
there and I did and all of a sudden
those two plots were unfurling at once
and falling in love with Matthew really
helped me realize the enormity of what I
lost when Aaron died and just as
importantly it helped me realize that my
love for Aaron and my grief for Aaron
and my love for Matthew are not opposing
forces there are just strands to the
same thread they're the same stuff I'm
what would my parents say I'm not
special dad for kids or like frankly but
I'm not I'm not special I know that I am
fully aware that all day every day all
around the world terrible things are
happening all the time like I said fun
person but like terrible things are
happening people are experiencing deeply
formative and traumatic losses everyday
and as part of my job this weird podcast
that I have I sometimes talk to people
about the worst thing that's ever
happened to them and sometimes that's
the loss of someone they love
sames days ago or weeks ago years ago
even decades ago and these people that I
interview they haven't closed themselves
around this loss and made at the center
of their lives they've lived their
worlds have kept spinning but they're
talking to me a total stranger but the
person they love who has died because
these are the experiences that mark us
and make us just as much as the joyful
ones and just as permanently long after
you get your last sympathy card or your
last hot dish like we don't look at the
people around us experiencing life's
joys and wonders and tell them to move
on do we we don't like send a card
that's a congratulations on your
beautiful baby and then five years later
think like another birthday party get
over it like yeah we get it he's five
Wow but grief is kind of one of those
things like falling in love or having a
baby or watching the wire on HBO where
you don't get it until you get it until
you do it and once you do it once it's
your love or your baby once it's your
grief and your front row at the funeral
you get it you understand what you're
experiencing is not a moment in time
it's not a bone that will reset but that
you've been touched by something chronic
something incurable it's not fatal but
sometimes grief feels like it could be
and if we can't prevent it in one
another what can we do what can we do
other than try to remind one another
that some things can't be fixed and not
all wounds are meant to heal we need
each other
to remember to help each other remember
the grief is this multitasking emotion
that you can and will be sad
happy you'll be grieving and able to
love in the same year or week the same
breath we need to remember that a
grieving person is going to laugh again
and smile again if they're lucky they'll
even find love again but yes absolutely
they're going to move forward but that
doesn't mean that they've moved on thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]